13-4 run over the last four minutes by  the hawks how will philly  respond they go to embiid he drives  loses the ball and they're going to call  a foul on atlanta  oh now maybe nate mcmillan will  challenge us  called on trae young  they still might decide to review this  but  obviously the technical is going to  stand no matter what on trey young and  embiid will shoot the free throw  now this is just because we're so high  up  it's difficult to see at the angle that  we're looking at  all you know is is that envy makes the  move  and all of a sudden falls forward now  is there a trip is that what they call  it  keep it down here  now from that angle you can't tell  whether he's tripped or not